materials in your game or game engine is
one of the hardest things to get right
in my experience now i've been spending
approximately the last three weeks
trying to hash out the best system for
my particular
game engine here that you're looking at
and i've gone back and forth with
different ways am i going to do pbr am i
not going to do pbr
what if the model has a texture like a
png
or something like that that includes
that includes with it and what if it
doesn't what if it just has some data
like some color data and stuff like that
and there's no actual texture how do you
handle that and there seems to be
nearly endless scenarios of different
ways people
do texturing and
yeah
it's obviously not endless but there are
a lot of different ways there's no
one-size-fits-all
everybody seems to be doing it slightly
different there are some standards you
can follow and you can and now
you got to kind of decide do i follow
some of these standards or do i come up
with my own system or do i support all
the standards and just kind of mash it
all in there
and
it's a lot of
design design decision to think of so i
spent a good amount of time getting this
whole pbr thing set up and setting up a
shader to handle the pbr workflow
and
when i'm finally nearing the end of this
whole
thing
i decided that this is
really convoluted and confusing and
there's no way
um
there's no smooth way to make this
happen the way i was doing it so i ended
up just backpedaling and that always
feels bad because you feel like you're
losing a lot of work you feel like you
spent tons of time doing this and the
whole everything you've done is being
reverted now this is sort of a
misconception
uh because all the time you spent
trying to do one thing and it maybe
didn't work
it's surprising how much you learned
it's surprising when you approach things
even other things now you have all this
bonus knowledge we'll say bonus
knowledge
of what other options are out there and
that often influences how things are
going to go in the future for you
especially for designing
your own particular material system now
obviously unity and unreal have their
ways of doing it and i'm sure that's
perfectly fine for them but as you might
know uh there those engines are
generally pretty heavy as in they have a
lot of options and for whatever game
you're in particular designing there's
no way you're using all those options so
if you're making your own game engine
often the reason you're doing this is
because you want to keep it lightweight
you don't want to have all this extra
bloat in there that ultimately just
makes all your
your game
your game a larger file and the engine
uh you won't you want it to you want to
reduce the amount of uh what's the right
word i guess hashing and caching you you
don't want your memory to be all
scattered in large chunks uh
that might make sense to computer
science people but other people but
basically you want things to be nice and
aligned you don't want stuff all over
the place and the more like stuff you
have that you're not using the more your
stuff in general is going to be
scattered in your memory which means
that your cpu is going to have to dump
its cash and load in this new stuff and
sometimes for no particular reason other
than it's just got it full of stuff
you're not using
that's a lot to think about
so
yeah
in preparing for this next update to my
uh archer engine
um previously named ancient archer i
still haven't updated the project name
uh but
yeah i'm basically having to make all
these decisions and i think
when it comes down to it you know i've
tried to implement pbr i sort of
backpedaled on it maybe i'll do it later
but it looks like it's more than i'm
going to necessarily need because
overall this this looks pretty darn good
right now i'm pretty happy with the way
models look with just like the blind
phone setup and some basic shadows so
we'll give it a quick run just as an
example here but all right so i've got
this like uh i think it's a car 98 or
something it's just like a sniper rifle
and i can load it into here
now when i got this off a
one of those sites i don't remember
exactly what site sorry
i got this model off some site might be
a little hard to see here but we have a
directional light and we have a gun
model and i'm pretty happy with the way
it looks it's got a nice shine a little
bit of jaggy edges but that's uh that
could be improved with some
anti-aliasing and stuff so not too big a
deal but this is not pbr this is just
blindfold with with some specular
highlights and stuff like that and
overall i like the look of this it looks
pretty good
um i'm pretty happy with that so is
there really a point in going to pbr if
you're happy with the way things look i
don't know obviously this could probably
look a lot better
uh in some ways and we could get better
reflections from the environment and all
that but that's not really a bridge i'm
ready to cross yet is what i've decided
at least not in this particular update
uh maybe someday absolutely but now
here's where
this is probably the most important
takeaway and the most important part
if you're making a game engine
you need to think about what game you're
making
now i'm making this game engine for a
game that i want to make that i don't
know of anybody else that's in general
using this engine maybe they will maybe
they won't
it's not really for me to decide even i
have to decide what i want in my game
and if i don't care that much about pbr
i don't need to include it and
ultimately pvr is going to be a
performance hit it's it's a lot more
calculations it's a lot heavier every
game and that's fine with today's
hardware really it's not that big of a
deal
but that is also just a consideration
and
i think for now
i'm okay with the way it is uh with this
look but that being said there are some
other issues here because these all load
from textures there's a whole set of
textures that come with this and they
all look pretty nice and there's a
roughness normal metalness ao now i'm
not using this ao texture
so it could look a little nicer with
that i don't think i'm using the
roughness either but those are prepared
for pbr however that's a whole other
thing that i'm going to talk about real
quick
and this is something that threw me for
a loop and probably cost me days of time
but at least at least now i know um and
it's it's this is more about relying on
other people's libraries uh you don't
know about other people's libraries all
that much sometimes
sometimes people put stuff in their
libraries that will just like
they'll look like they do something but
they don't actually do what they say
they do and it's not necessarily even
their fault so i'm going to go let's see
here i'm going to go to my uh i guess
texture loader here and i've got uh you
see asim that's open asset importer it's
just a public library we're going to
take a look at this material file now
something about this material file is
you know when you're importing stuff and
you're loading up
models and textures there's a way to
grab the textures from the files
obviously they handle all that and you
know it's a lot of work it's a big job
but what they have here is a bunch of
different things about the texture they
have map modes they have operations
they've got uh what else texture mapping
what's the difference i don't know but
yeah there's there's all these little
things
and
when you get to the texture type
this is where things get weird because i
started i started grabbing pbr models so
i was trying to implement this pbr and i
decided hey look like we're gonna
we need a good pbr model to test and i
thought i thought that if a model was
labeled as a pbr model like someone
designed it with substance painter for
pbr
that
when you load it up with smp and you get
the texture type
i thought that the pbr materials would
be labeled as pbr materials but they're
not
they're they're not
in any case in all these pvr models not
a single one had any of these pbr
materials that asim has in their file
so
maybe some do maybe they're just
preparing for the future but in all the
ones i tested nobody even designing pbr
materials actually uses these so i was i
was confused i was like why why are
these even in here then because i
designed this whole system i changed
everything for the pbr to check
specifically for the pbr materials and
it turns out the pr models don't even
use the pbr
material tags they just use these old
tags they use these old
what they call legacy i don't think
their legacy they appear to be still
current
so like there there's no base color it's
just called diffuse
and there's no
normal can what does what does normal
camera even mean i don't even know
uh
i don't even know it's just a normal
maybe they just had to give it a
different name because normals is
already here but yeah your normals are
normals they're not they're not called
normal camera because they're pbr
and all this stuff it's just you know
all these pbr stuff use these old
standard ones that we're used to they're
not using this new setup and that that
literally cost me days of work
implementing all this stuff and changing
everything to adapt to it just to find
out that
it's not even used
so
i guess the whole takeaway from this is
uh design for what you're actually doing
don't try to follow the trends too much
don't try to do what everybody else is
doing don't try to prepare for what
other people might want specifically
implement what you need for your
particular game and that's my rant about
materials i'd be happy to hear your
comments about this whole thing down
below
uh try not to bash ask them too much i
know they're
people have a lot of complaints about it
but there doesn't seem to be a better
model loader it's like if you can't
improve it or come up with a better one
you probably shouldn't complain about it
i know it sound like i'm complaining
about it but i'm really not i'm just
very i'm more confused more than
anything i'm confused as to why
i don't even know if it's their fault or
if it's the
designers of old models or new models
full i don't know whose fault this is
but i just don't i literally just don't
understand and couldn't find really any
information on why they have specific
pbr materials in here but nobody uses
them
so i it's it's more of a lack of
understanding it's not me complaining
and i would love to hear the answer if
it's out there or something
all right seeing the next one peace out
[Music]
[Music]